last week I don't know if you saw this
everyone's talking about it Mark
Wahlberg posted his grueling daily
schedule on Instagram I know if you saw
this but everyone's talking about it a
lot of people were commenting on how
rigorous it was here it is he starts to
stay at 2:30 in the morning you can see
all this crazy stuff he hits the gym at
3:40 in the morning in the morning he's
in bed by 7:30 p.m. and there's all of
us working out an incredible strain and
it's just amazing and I was blown away
but would you think of a schedule Andy I
mean it's okay you know I mean it's it's
not that different from my daily routine
I really you don't think it's very
different from your routine no okay do
you mind if I show everyone your daily
schedule well I'd prefer you didn't hey
check this out ladies and gentleman
incredible here we go 2:30 a.m. get up
to pee 2:35 eat leftover chicken wings
2:45 finish peeing three buy samurai
swords from infomercial 3:30 Twitter
feud with James Woods for 30 borrow
tomatoes from neighbor's garden five
open robe walk around the block six
bourbon numero uno 6:30 watch yoga class
through hole 730 by Morris my swords
from infomercial eight visit bakery to
see if any custom cakes weren't picked
up 8:30 eat a giant slice of happy 90th
Barnard cake Sal samurai swords on eBay
at 10:00 11:00 vodka numero uno 11:30
creep around YouTube makeup tutorials
for two hours 1:30 indica choose sativa
3 siesta port 25 arrive at work 4:30
tape Conan Cho 5 nap 5:30 finished
taping on itself 5:45 bed
all day see you like I said it's not
that different from why no it's pretty
much the same it's pretty much the same
gotcha
here's a I'll tell you later here's a
word story here's a word story in
Milwaukee you know what you did you know
what you did not talking in the audience
I'm talking to someone who works for me
I said those things gonna kill and then
we have unnecessary lines afterwards and
he said keep it in anyway it's the one
on the right wait your hand
[Applause]
how great is it to walk around with an
applause but
very talented head writer
you